hi everyone it's Jerry I am hopping into
an hourly super Blitz Arena
joining the party a bit late
about 44 minutes remaining 57 minute
tournament three plus oh
let's see who we get
all right same old Jets
let's go Sicilian
okay
open Bishop B5 open Sicilian
all right big moment
a lot of variety for white very
classical let's Bishop E2
take some care over D5 now
no F4 okay
it's the only spot this guy could go
get him there
ff4 Queen here
pairing to meet F5 with Bishop C4 this
is the worst minor piece
so I definitely don't want to take here
this is my best piece you could say
so
I would prefer to exchange my good
Bishop for bad Bishop than my best minor
piece for their worst minor piece I
guess is what it's coming down to
okay so it seems like
this move is never happening otherwise
The Rook would be more appropriately
placed on F1
um
I'm just gonna put this guy here
I don't want to play B5 I don't think
right now at least
because I'm concerned about this here
and that
um something about the C6 Square I don't
want to weaken that
I might be inviting a knight to get into
C6 that best piece or this worst piece
in two
I could soon morph into a best piece
okay
we'll go here I'm anticipating that at
some point maybe
this guy might be mobile and I'll have
the option to play E4
my Rook will be supporting okay maybe I
should think a bit more about this
advance
now that the Rook is no longer in a on
the a file
yeah let's or you know what no that's
still not weaken that square I'm going
to go here
you know
if this this bishop takes I could
recapture
and on this this bishop takes Knight
Queen takes my Rook is supporting
I think I do well to maintain this
tension not give this square up my eye
is really on this knife I don't want to
capture it I don't want to give it a
good Square
here maybe here
all right
a thinking moment for white
and also I should mention this crossed
my mind after this move
but I think I'd be inviting sacrifices
after the push and
even though there's there wouldn't be a
quick way to
invite another piece towards my king
it's still a little bit scary
so that was a really big decision there
if I want
giving up
their best minor piece I think the dark
Square Bishop was best
and hmm
how do I want to take I think I want to
move back so let's go here and now after
the recapture there isn't a threat
so I have a moment to breathe
I'd like to get my dark Square Bishop on
this diagonal
if I push I give this square up
maybe okay to do that
um
maybe move my Bishop
I gotta get a move on let's go with this
one
not sure exactly how The Bishop's gonna
arrive here but I'm I'm gunning for that
in a spot to recapture with the Rook I
don't want to allow this Pawn to become
past
minute mark
team White
okay maybe this is a little bit more
appealing now
yeah I'm gonna get this in now
and maybe maybe I could pivot
um
it seems a little passive but let's go
here
oh
so they are kind of walking into this
one
I think I want to keep the Queens on
yeah
and maybe I grab some space now I like
the control I have over this position
huh I have this defended so
I could recapture with pieces this
Knight is really good it's my
favorite piece in the current position
so they missed this
I believe at least
no follow brick C1 if they were exchange
and C5
and I think I do well to maintain
the tension on the C file
Knight also guards queen against Queen
D7 my queen is ready to be really active
Queen F2
and I think I should play this straight
away
pressure on a lot of stuff pick off a
pawn
now the night's ready to sweep in maybe
made on each two it's nearby
so I could definitely get the queen
exchange if I want that
let's take first
let's take again enter
seventh rank
Big Fork
gotta go faster oh I had a tactic Rook
takes Bishop there
um gotta go quicker
boom I'll slip
oh my time
oh
barely got that one my goodness
very sloppy okay I think I like how I I
think I would play the middle game like
I did again but a little bit faster
it was way too close a call it's
fumbling there with the pieces at the
end
Hedrick takes Bishop with the Fallout
Fork missed my chance for a trick Fork
all right Alexandro
okay
it was a long game took the wind out of
me a bit
all right
let's just watch over C4
are they there
okay they're back connection issue baby
I love taking on this structure that was
a good for bad Bishop Exchange
big grip over E5
and how do I want to play this
preferred I would prefer to only move my
knight here after this guy moves
I want to move him and push
this guy away
all right let's let's just reinforce my
center for starters okay they're trying
to kill me
that's what this is
okay let's let's let's jump in now or
now let's let's play this one stopping
Queen H4
and also
this is nearby
you know let's play this right now
like I think about this move now that
the Rook is on H6 my knight
may feel a bit more comfortable dropping
into G5
I am coordinated well on G5 so makes
sense to maybe go to this non-central
Square
okay where are
any tricks I think
I think I wanna
yeah let's go here
so watch out for this one Knight takes
Pawn okay also I can't take like that
okay and now this one and nearby there's
a queen trap or actually this is already
a trap
she is
toast
so drawn to this
structure right away but
I could win a queen win the queen
all right I think that's here
let's watch out for the night when he
goes to F6
all right
it's the easiest way
I don't know I guess they got this guy
here
playing playing very slow
all right let's come back over here
maybe you know what maybe I should have
captured first and waited to see which
way the recapture was and only then made
the decision with my Rook
this Knight is
kind of stupid
you know
I'm not really playing this the best way
but I'm just going to eliminate any
possible tricks give back a little
material to release the pressure yeah
they just Mouse slipped but
I was going to follow up rook C1
Queen really didn't knock out any thing
valuable
um when I won the queen it was just a
queen for a pawn so
okay
it's ready to say round three Arena
format all right we're gonna get a
double Berserker
all right Bishop F4
no quick Knight G Knight C3 so I have to
worry about
white converging on C7 this is usually
not a good idea this guy's eyes just
became a lot wider
the C file opens up
in fact let's play this straight away
and look forward to developing this guy
here right right right now on move one
if this bishop was here I would have the
win
of a uh
of the I would win the exchange I don't
mind taking on the double death Pawns
okay
okay let's go here this is tempting
as well
Knight B4 yeah they needed to release
the tension there
repair my structure I'm guessing
but now it's just the win of two minor
pieces for the queen they should be
capturing the bishop thinks this is the
best they could do I think
yeah better to play a position where
it's two minor pieces versus the queen
then just being down a flat piece
oh just up a night now
um
and let's just get this guy out of
Harm's Way
yeah recapture the Knight
Knight C5 Queen B4
Queen A6
actually I'm on the queen still
okay
simple chest from here
be a trading machine give back more
material
and go wild with the queen
try and find an active post
okay put pressure on stuff
it's a weak point
you could take a check first
I'd have made on the H file
at some point
I'm on The Rook
let's defend everything
hit on H2
can pre-move it okay
still 30 minutes to go where are we at
321 in here
uh let's try E4
why not
E4 D4
okay it's an unusual
maneuver for the night I have seen it
before though
uh let's flick this one in
before they play five and try and cancel
out the bishop moves
okay
uh I don't want to take
hmm
let's go here
and
actually let's let's go with this one
see if they bite
yeah
they they want me to take here so that
this Knight
can be helped
I'm gonna lock this side of the board
down this is a this is definitely a
struggling night
uh what is a good approach
go
I wanna I wanna play this move I'm so
I'm gonna I'm gonna play here connect my
Rooks
I don't I don't foresee the queen side
opening up so
I could get this in now
take with the queen want her to drift
towards the F6 Square
yeah they're just kind of shuffling at
this point
um what do I need to do how do I break
things down I could play Bishop F6
or try and get my knight right here
where my queen is
yeah night night should be fantastic on
D3 I I up a possible jump towards this
side
let's back off
this move okay
let's play this one
pressure here okay now they're ready to
maybe go there or
let's get out of the way
night here was interesting too
so they're the kind of out of room they
have to go for this one
and given that they are out of room
let's keep some more pieces on
for the moment
oh I missed that that was even a move
wow
okay
how are they defending this King here is
not working they have to try King there
but then there's this my idea is to pile
up there
yeah so now this is squashed
okay I got my pick
with the Knight
I almost don't even want to take that
Rook
all right I'll take the Rook
go here
try and get the Queens off first I don't
want to push here too fast and open this
up
okay let's go with this one first and
then we go with the break
stopping that
kind of fumbling with these last couple
moves not the cleanest approach but
finally getting a successful break
and go here
this guy is good on G4
prove the queen ah okay I can always get
the Queens off
yeah I want to prevent all counter plays
so
so let's do just that
defend B4
twice now
and this one right here
and we got Rook here next
promotion coming up
okay
yeah they kind of ran out of room
and too much space on
both sides of the board
okay
let's go D5 greasy aluminum
how'd you come up with that name
okay
defend my Center prepare to meet Queen
B3 Queen B6
I'm in time to exchange queens and stop
a B5 break if they if they go for this
C5 move
I want to take with the pawn maintain a
pawn in the center and in the event of
this I want to be able to take with the
pawn and have a pawn island of four
if I took with this I'd have double
isolated pawns after Pawn takes
so they're gearing up for that one
I think I want to play here now that the
Queens are off I don't mind making these
weaknesses and if I could prevent E4
then
I could do more than prevent E4 in this
case
I don't think any sacrifices
wonderful on this on this point maybe if
the queen was still around but
maybe at the end of the day this wasn't
so good because they are able to get any
form
all right we'll see I have the bishop
pair
I guess I take and then say the Knight
is under control
it's Castle
Bishop controls the Knight let's expand
a little bit Knight on B6 should be
pretty good
this crossed my mind as well but I might
just be inviting another E4
yeah let's play it
this one first Knight F6 or Knight B6
I think I like this one I know in case
this file opens up I
maybe we just get some exchanges in oh I
could also pinpoint the dark squares a
little bit King H2 try for H4 okay so
the Knight is on his back foot
um oh also this guy is unprotected I
could have noted that as soon as Rook F2
is in there
so I could get in B4
maybe this guy goes back home no he's
going there
okay
I think I think this is all fine
no let me hang on
concerned about a rook getting here
let's pile up on the pun
hit now a third time
okay
this is losing
C6
uh let's start with this one
here
there's no Rook B7 okay
I guess here is fine
no I missed this move
okay
um they could take here actually I I
should I should have been thinking about
the capture here I'm forgetting that
uh the Knight is no longer on F1
defending G3
Okay so
maybe the first this take improve the
king they have a nice lead on the clock
but could get a rook ending rum up a
pawn but it's not clear
right there exchange here here Rook
there
yeah they're gonna get this guy or this
guy
not gonna be easy
oh
what were they seeing there
I don't know what the story is with that
one so this I could play Knight takes I
take the pawn pawn takes I take the Rook
Pawn push I take the pawn
no follow-up forks from B5
let's get to this
dream rank
threatening mate
or a past Pawn I'm going to take away
from the center uh actually it should be
mate here check check checkmate
so another another reason to have taken
away from the center but I was mostly
just looking to have a an outside pass
Pawn
21 minutes to go Euro chess let's try D4
D4 C4
and maybe try a Catalan let's try
Catalan
give up my C4 Pawn if they want it
you know they don't want it
I'm gonna get this E4 breaking
Knight D2 E4
really can't be stopped
trying to overtake the the center their
Center Point
to give it up or deal with this Pawn
pushing this guy around
um I'm gonna take with the knight uh I
because I like my Bishop better than
their Bishop I'm gonna try and do
something here
try and maybe demonstrate that
this diagonal is more influential than
this one
and it makes the break
harder with C5
um what about a D5 break
be asking for this
Queen defense that
okay
let's go here I'm offering up a pawn
they want it
I don't know that it's great though I
could take here I'd be on the bishop I'd
be on C6
and I think now I could push though
this take advantage of the bishop
it is unprotected
so I don't have the greatest structure
here but I think this is a
favorable Pawn break for me
we'll see
what black comes up with I'm ready to
chop twice on C6
or just you know if they exchange here
I'm going to chop there and chop there
could maybe be a case where I win the
exchange let's take with the pawn
and okay that's an interesting way to
defend Rook is unprotected
not really seeing a way I could take
advantage of that
hmm it's a good move
I like that okay
hmm
that's a good move
defending defending everything
hmm
all right
let's try this one
yeah I don't know that this was this
wasn't a good idea I don't think
okay this is a big change of plans my
intention was this or actually my
intention was to take here and then here
but in the end there's that one
so um
it's a positional Pawn sacrifice now
okay
these guys are at least under control
uh I am definitely not better I'm down
the pond
I wanted to come here anyhow so I don't
mind
the the attack
yeah King there I'd be asking for the
Rooks doubling might as well just get
out of Harm's Way
okay
I don't know how I'm supposed to proceed
okay this guy I guess could
do something else maybe maybe my king is
useful here you know
pressure on F4
yeah my opponent's not sure what to do
either
okay maybe maybe we need one Rook off
I'm not entirely sure why
so
okay I get one Rook off
can I get to the back rank
let's keep a rook on
maybe Rook D1
gonna go back and forth
the king is a hair closer to the center
about the light Square Bishop exchange
and then
I don't know not sure how to play this
I'm down a pawn and miscalculated Rook
D7 was good I have a Time Edge that's
about it
this one
16 minutes to go this tournament's
flying by
uh let's go here I don't want to do this
too soon The Rook will enter after the
exchange on D3
okay oh how about this let's go for a
maneuver Target this Pawn
hmm
let's go here and then return with the
Knight
to D4 defending this
and now
maybe I feel comfortable playing this
one and this one
control the knights or control the
Knight
enter there that is true
Knight can't be challenged King should
step over
trying to Rattle the bishop
I think this is a good idea I think
they're in trouble now
they're in a pin oh I'm in trouble
Bishop takes Bishop is check oh
yeah that's a big mess
I get this one on the clock
oh that was an ugly game
okay
I got 21 26 is in first
it is
totally up in the air okay we got a
berserk game
alrighty
let's take towards the center
yeah I was just saying in an earlier
game this structure isn't the greatest
double isolated beat puns they they
could have done that
but they could have done this to me they
didn't
flight Square
maintain the bishop
and now
get an A6 and maybe
just double
no Bishop A5 I'm defended
I'm defended they missed that
okay I just won a big piece
and let's trade
control the Knight or
let's go with this
yeah I'm ready to hop into a big Square
um I control
try and control stuff
and applying the oh my my goodness the
time
my night is out of play
okay
let's stop that pawn
let's go for this one
okay feel a little bit more comfortable
entirely
just a little
hmm
prove the king it is an ending
I could take my Rook is defended
okay I have a nice path towards the
center
where's the mate
just push the pawn
just enough gas in the tank
watch out for skewers
oh they can't even take
they got a bunch of Pawns
okay sloppy
that was sloppy okay this is the pack
leader let's try C4
yeah tough to adjust these berserk games
from three to
three minutes two minutes and a half
all right Queen's Gambit declined
H6 now
or after castles okay
um
let me initiate the the capture now
hop in
all right let's cast so I'm giving them
an opportunity to create a
majority
let me actually anticipate this idea I
don't want to see this and then B5 so
okay
seems
and let's go here if they do change the
structure I want to be able to
eventually react with E4
okay
let's chop
and let me challenge this Knight
I would like to see Knight takes
I get to build my Center
might be tougher for black to expand on
the queen side okay so we could have
mass exchanges
let's start with this one
I have C4 if they take they're taking
with the pawn
okay I'm also prepared to take on an
isolated Pawn can I win this guy this
Rook can't go too soon
pressure on A6 so
well centralized I have an eye on this
one they're very active
very active
okay releasing the pressure
on A6 but I don't want my queen oh I'm
also giving up this Pawn
ugh
it really isn't a
good reason I could see why they can't
just take that
I should have pushed D5
okay
down another Pawn
it's work ahead for me
I have a file I have some pressure here
I should be on the lookout for a trick
an F7
Queen E5 seems good
any of these three I like the
centralization
you know let's watch out for Knight G4
even though my Queen's here currently
I'm now free to go somewhere else
pinpointing B6 now
I have control over D5
no piece could jump there right now a
little lead on the clock
see
let's take once stay active hitting the
bishop in Pawn now
let's not forget about F7
okay
I don't know that I want to take that
let me challenge the queen
there's some fancy Discovery she's she's
way too good in this Square
okay
about this inch my way in
hitting the Rook
I could take here with Chuck
or this
this and this
think I'm winning now
if I took first king takes and then gave
the check there's a rook block
I tried switching the order
okay I have enough on that though
take with the bishop stay directly on
this one Rook there I can win the pawn
lucky to get back in that one okay
seven to go got 30 with fire
we need to get two more games in still
no guarantee
to overtake first
I'm not gonna berserk
should I
Maybe
see who we got
seven minutes
let's not do it
maybe the second game
could still try something Sharp
fishing land
gonna go for a fine cut out
yeah no fishing
it's tough to break down that point
this guy here
I don't want to Castle too soon
not sure I want to take on
uh King's Indian attack
position okay although
um
yeah it's a it's a little it's a little
bit different I don't know that the Rook
is so well placed on this Square
okay
trying to activate my light Square
Bishop
I have control over the minor piece
jumps to G5
let's get this one in first
um
yeah but why that one first let's be
consistent Bishop A6 said A5 let's go
Bishop A6 and now here
if Knight D2 this gives me a moment to
transfer my Bishop to a great Square
it's almost as if I initially developed
my
light Square Bishop outside the pawn
chain now
and this guy is a huge
Defender for
my king
okay light Square Bishops off
this was my idea my queen just inching
my way maybe she goes here Queen
exchange is definitely cool with me
I don't have to worry about any attack
although in this position with no light
Square Bishops around no
seeing an attack let's let's still go
here
really having some fun this D3 Square
Queen is secure Bishop's watching out
for any night hops I have this under
control
flight Square I don't think is
appropriate at this moment
expecting the C file to open up
some point
could be Queen E4
oh yeah they missed that they might
resign my oh one more game in got 34.
performances
be winning out on with performance
rating if I could get one more game in
even if this guy wins
maybe he berserked I don't know I think
it would say berserk though right next
to the name if he berserked
okay let's see if I could sneak this
last game in
okay
I should have started with E4
okay we still be a little bit sharper
these decisions
E6
have a passer
B5 move B5 isn't quite a move let's stop
B5
they're also securing their Bishop post
okay Queen what about a queen check let
me let me flick this one in
coin exchange if if the bishop
recaptures I could play Bishop F4 and
now this guy is mobile so this should be
very dangerous for black even though
there's the Queens are off
this guy could easily run wild it's got
a castled
Knight H5 I could probably hang out here
I'm able to improve
with an attack
um
Bishop D6 might be nearby
okay
gotta go fast
I'm not going fast threatening to win
upon Maybe
might be vulnerable on the C file this
is an unprotected Bishop
Rook d8
it's probably a move okay
let's start with this one
okay
I don't know if this is the greatest
they could play B5
they're going for
I'm prepared to
just recapture on this point okay
I think I need some trades
two minutes left it's probably not going
to finish
fortunately
night here I win The Exchange
oh that move too I win the exchange
would they resign
I'm gonna win the exchange
oh
so much for that
they're getting it back I miss Bishop F6
they shouldn't take I don't think right
away at least
should be better though
that this Rook is not comfortable
playing the role of
her babysitter
to watch over the pawn
once cut out the night jump
a rook here I could play this and then
that
how they
well
change of plans I'm gonna go like this
they're offering a draw
um I want to win
a draw
would give me two in the win
maybe should I take the draw
away Pawn
King here I could push they're not even
threatening that though
okay now I'm like not even better
um
yeah
can you do
just gonna try and win this one
position
The Rook is so active
I have a skewer Bishop there I also have
this to cover it
whoa now I'm winning the bishop
okay
yeah they fumbled there a little bit
yeah Rook C4
so one king and pawn ending
no fancy tries really
I guess this one right here just some
accuracy to not allow
position where I have to leave defense
of the pawn
let's see if we could
get this mate
okay back to tournament
yeah that guy slipped up I had my chance
to take first I didn't I don't like
taking the Jaws though
I want to just play it all out
okay
so
that flew by nine games ten games nine
counted
all right nice
mix of games
throw a good games all
okay uh Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video
the comments section below always fun to
hop into these events from time to time
yeah feel free to leave any feedback
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye